[Music]
hospitals generate a lot of dirty
laundry from patient gowns and sheets to
cleaning racks some facilities do the
washing in-house but to free up hospital
space some send theirs out to industrial
sized laundry operations that deal in
high volume with bigger and better
equipment the hospital sends all fabric
items to the laundry including bed
linens towels patient gowns bibs and
cleaning rags the only exception is
Surgical linens which are usually
disposable the laundry company picks up
the order and delivers it to the plant
next workers unload the bags of soiled
laundry on large rolling carts they
weigh each one for internal statistical
purposes and scan its barcode to track
the laundry for each hospital workers
handling the bags wear gloves at all
times the bags are plastic which is more
suitable than cloth for containing
liquid odor and bacteria workers rip
each one open and without touching the
contents dump them on the conveyor they
discard the bag in a suction device that
sends it to a baling system the bales of
bags go to a recycling facility that
turns them into garbage bags and other
polyethylene products from this point on
everything is automated the conveyor
drops the soiled laundry into a sturdy
cloth bag once the bag reaches 120
pounds the conveyor automatically stops
loading
[Music]
the filled bag travels to an overhead
conveyor system which leads to one of
several stainless-steel tunnel shaped
washing machines inside a large rotating
screw pushes the load through to
pre-soak then moves on to six chemical
wash cycles designed to remove tough
stains such as blood and iodine next are
five treatment cycles to soften the
fabric and normalize the pH level then
three rinses the load of now clean
laundry exits the tunnel washer and
enters a hydraulic press the press
applies around 12 tons of weight to
squeeze out the residual water the load
comes out compressed into what they call
a cake a conveyor transfers it to an
elevator which transports it to the
drying area the conveyor puts two cakes
at a time into the dryer an infrared
sensor inside signals the dryer to stop
when the load is dry about 22 minutes
later a revolving paddle called a cake
breaker separates the stuck together
items to prepare them for sorting from
this point on automation ends and manual
sorting begins workers pull different
categories of items and toss them into
designated linen hoppers that are hooked
up to scales
[Music]
when a bag hits the target weight it
automatically drops down onto a conveyor
which leads to the final processing area
here items are either folded or bought
packaged in plastic bags workers load
the bulk items into a vacuum system
which feeds into automated bagging
machines the machines have either a
built-in scale which weighs the bag as
it fills or a photocell which counts the
items dropping into the bag once the bag
reaches the target weight or count the
machine heat seals and releases it
[Music]
certain items have to be folded luckily
a machine automatically folds bed pads
bath towels and patient gowns by
flipping over the ends with short blasts
of air the neatly folded items collect
underneath the machine then travel by
conveyor to the shipping preparation
area here workers stack them onto
rolling carts a different folding
machine handles the larger items such as
bed sheets and flannel blankets a worker
clamps an item to the feeder then the
machine using rollers and straps
processes the item until it's neatly
folded the clean laundry goes back onto
carts into the truck and back to the
hospital
[Music]